die jüngsten sonntagsfragen haben bei
vielen tiefen Schock hinterlassen laut
Insa steht dort die afd-bundesweit bei
16,5% damit knapp hinter der SPD mit 20
Prozent und vor den Grünen mit 14%, das
wirklich erstaunlicher aber die
Rechtspopulisten haben laut Analyse ein
Wählerpotenzial von zusätzlichen 10%
also sprich jeder vierte kann sich
vorstellen die AFD zu wählen da sind wir
mittendrin im Thema von Antje Hermann
auf was glauben Sie wer trägt dafür die
Verantwortung na das ist ein
kollektiv-ergebnis aber am schwersten
trifft eigentlich die Verantwortung die
CDU die über lange Zeit hinweg
Kernthemen die den konservativen
zugeordnet werden vernachlässigt hat und
Platz gelassen hat das andere sich an
diesem Thema abarbeiten das ist als
wichtig ist aus meiner Sicht die Frage
des Euros das war damals die Gründung
der AFD die Frage der Geldwert
Stabilität die Frage auch das
Wohlstandes im Lande wenn sie sich die
Gründer Väter und Mütter angucken die
alle nicht arbeiten AFD sind die hatten
das Thema mit dem Euro das war auch
damals völlig berechtigt diese Frage zu
stellen nach der Finanzmarktkrise das
ist auch immer noch nicht behoben das
Problem ist eher schlimmer geworden und
das zweite Thema ist Migration und zwar
mit dem was da noch dranhängt nämlich
einer oft mangelhaften Integration das
bedeutet wieder wohlstandsgefährdung im
Bereich der sozialen Sicherungssysteme
wenn mehr Leute raus kriegen als
reinzahlen und das bedeutet aber auch
eine Verschlechterung beim Thema Ordnung
und Sicherheit auch im konservativen
Kernthema dass das linke und Grüne nicht
sehr verunsichert wenn durch Zuwanderung
solche Sachen sind das merkt man ihren
Reden wenn ich sagen ist alles halb so
schlimm dafür soll sich nicht aufregen
aber die Bürger reden sich auf und ich
kann das auch nachvollziehen es sind
immer irgendwelche Einzelfälle wenn es
mal zu Übergriffen auch auf Frauen
insbesondere kommt das ist natürlich
Quatsch das weiß auch jeder merkt das
man muss ja nur weil man eine
Wochenbilanz der ganzen Lokalzeitungen
machen und dann sieht man wie viele
Angriffe und Übergriffe es gegeben hat
das Thema das auch im Rahmen steht ist
eben wie gesagt wie wir sollen die
sozialen Sicherungssysteme
stabilisiert werden jetzt haben wir eine
Regierung die ist so weit treibt dass
sogar der Kapitalstock bröckelt im Land
das heißt die Firmen die stabil auch in
den nächsten Jahren und Jahrzehnten
sozusagen weiter für sorgen werden dass
wir immer schön liquide sind weil die
gut verdienen das ist zum Teil nicht in
allen Branchen aber zum Teil in der
Schwierigkeiten geraten also insgesamt
ist der Wohlstand gefährdet
konservatives Thema die Ordnung und
Sicherheit ist nicht mehr gewährleistet
konservatives Thema und die Frage des
Euros steht auch im Raum und da hat die
CDU nicht geliefert FDP in meinen Augen
auch nicht aber das können sie ja
nachher korrigieren wenn sie wollten ähm
und deswegen ist es völlig klar dass die
Leute diese Themen beschäftigen sich
dann eine Protestpartei suchen die Sie
wählen das ist die AFD
für die Linke aber jetzt ist die AFD was
glauben Sie sie waren früher bei den
Grünen sie haben sich immer für die
Demokratie eingesetzt das glauben Sie
wie gefährlich kann das werden naja das
kann immer gefährlich werden egal ob der
linke extremistische Partei sondern
Rechte extremistische Partei das ist
Rille das spielt keine Rolle aber das
kann immer gefährlich werden wenn die
Leute einfach keinerlei Vertrauen mehr
haben zu der Wagenburg in der
vermeintlichen Mitte die wir inzwischen
ja begutachten können aus den vier
Parteien FDP SPD Grüne und CDU die
bilden so eine Art Wagenburg und die
Frage ist wie groß ist die eigentlich
diese Mitte ich bin inzwischen der
Meinung wenn man sich anguckt was links
und rechts alles möglich ist dass die
gar nicht so groß ist und aus meiner
Sicht wird es dann immer schwerer werden
vernünftige Koalitionen zu bilden die
dazu in der Lage sind die Bundesländer
oder den Bund insgesamt voranzubringen
sondern wir kriegen immer wieder solche
Regierungen die sich gegenseitig
blockieren oder gegenseitig sozusagen
nichts können und dann geht's im Land
nicht vorwärts und das in der Krise das
ist das Problem dass dabei entsteht
politisch haben wir gerade bei Frau
hermenge gehört die FDP hat ihr Pferd
wegbekommen vor allem auch die Union hat
ihr Fett wegbekommen was glauben Sie wie
viel Schuld trägt auch die SPD wie viel
Schuld trägt auch der Kanzler
die SPD hat natürlich ihre Facharbeiter
in den letzten Jahren im Stich gelassen
die Industrialisierung
sozusagen
auf Deubel kommen raus grüne Politik zu
machen das kommt bei den kernwählern der
SPD nicht gut an und wir sehen ja zum
Beispiel in Thüringen das die AFD dort
den höchsten Anteil an
arbeiterwählern hat nicht mehr die SPD
und deswegen appelliere ich an die SPD
sich auch an wieder zurück zu besinnen
auf ihre Wurzeln sich für die
den Mittelstand und die Facharbeiter
wieder einzusetzen das vermisse ich in
der jetzigen Politik sie sind soziale
Demokrat auf welche Themen haben Sie das
Gefühl wird zu viel Schwerpunkt derzeit
gelegt naja wir haben eine grüne
Politik der Bundesregierung die
rücksichtslos
diese die Maßstäbe verschiebt es wird
keine Rücksicht genommen auf die
Lebenswirklichkeit der Menschen und und
schauen Sie die Reaktion auf die
Energiepreise war ja nicht sich mal die
Frage zu stellen müssen wir nicht
eigentlich mehr Stromangebot in
Deutschland haben sondern man hat
einfach zugesehen wie sich rein Weise
Großindustrie nach China oder Amerika
aus dem Stau gemacht und am Ende bleiben
die Facharbeiter zurück wir haben jetzt
noch keine wirkliche arbeitslosenkrise
aber jetzt reißen die Ketten und wenn
ein eine Kette reißt dann kommt der
Mittelstand ins ins toeln das ist
sozusagen das Herz unserer
Industriegesellschaft und
kräftig operiert
sein Minus von 10,7 % in der Industrie
in den Auftragsbüchern in der
Produktionsaufträgen ihre Partei regiert
mit hat man solche Zahlen zu wenig
erstmal glaube ich ist es ein extrem
wichtiges Thema was sie uns da heute
mitgebracht haben weil es so ein Thema
ist was glaube ich auch nicht mehr
unbedingt die Frage der der reinen
parteipolitischen Auseinandersetzung ist
sondern wie wollen wir über Politik
sprechen und wie bewerten wir Politik
und wenn wir uns an die Zahlen
erinnern die Sie gerade genannt haben
und uns auch angucken wie gerade zum
Beispiel die Ampel bewertet wird auch
wie wir es Freie Demokraten zum Beispiel
bewertet werden dann ist es ja oft der
Streit der irgendwo dann ist ja negativ
beschieden wird aber ich glaube wir
müssen wieder anfangen auch politisch zu
schreiben weil wir vermissen irgendwo
den Ideen wird Bewerb und damit kommt es
natürlich zu diesem gefühlten
Einheitspreis den wir irgendwo haben der
natürlich irgendwo dem geschuldet ist
glaube ich dass wir die letzten 16 Jahre
wirklich Stillstand hat nur noch
spannender finde ich ja nicht nur dass
Menschen damit ernsthaft mit dem
Gedanken spielen die AFD zu wählen
sondern ja vorstellen in Deutschland was
aber sozusagen auch noch zur Wahrheit
gehört ist welche Lösungskompetenz wird
denn der AFD damit gegeben und die ist
ja sehr gering nur 16 also ich glaube es
sind 60 Prozent der AFD Wähler die auch
sagen die AFD löst gar keine politischen
Probleme also diese Partei ist absolut
gemacht also die Lösungen dann kommen
oder nicht aber das lässt mich sozusagen
hoffen weil ich glaube wenn wir lernen
dass wir wieder Lösungen vernünftig
präsentieren dann sind diese Menschen
sozusagen nicht verloren also die wählen
Hitler Menschen zu Lösungen zu liefern
ja auch wir machen Fehler und ich glaube
auch wir müssen da besser werden klar
also wir versuchen jetzt gerade ja das
sie haben sie gerade gesagt mit der die
Industrialisierung wir versuchen da ja
auch ganz massiv dagegen zu halten aber
wenn wir uns über gewisse Punkte
unterhalten was auch in den letzten
Wochen ja auch dann oft in den Medien
hochkommen denken wir zum Beispiel man
das Thema Kindergrundsicherung wenn
Christian Lindner da Haushalt tierisch
völlig richtig meines Erachtens
argumentiert auch verantwortungsbewusst
argumentiert
erinnere mich gerne manche Schlagzeile
die ihm da im Grunde unterstellt hat
dass er kein Herz für Kinder hat
plötzlich ne versteht auch die CDU zu
auf Klimapolitik hat auch Friedrich Merz
das zu oft zum Thema gemacht ich glaube
das wird jetzt zunehmend mehr ein Thema
denn wenn man sich die Welt anschaut
kann er da fremd brennt in Spanien in
Frankreich wird um Wasser gerungen in
Asien sanieren sich die Menschen zu Tode
weil es heiß und feucht gleichzeitig ist
und wir führen ideologische Debatten
über die Industrialisierung auf der
einen Seite
auf der anderen Seite
interessieren die CDU setzt sie zu sehr
auf Themen mit denen sie Wähler
verlieren könnte ich glaube die CDU kann
das noch viel mehr tun bei der letzten
Bundestagswahl das sind Zahlen von der
anderen Stiftung oder sich von mir
letzten Bundestagswahl hat die CDU eine
Million Wählerstimmen an die Grünen
verloren wegen des Klimate Themas also
weil offensichtlich unsere Partei doch
nicht genügend Kompetenz oder
Vertrauenswürdigkeit ähnlich um den Tag
gelegt und ich glaube das ist bei
Friedrich Merz angekommen
die Zahlen habe ich mir tatsächlich
nicht genau angeschaut ich habe jetzt
hier in der Berlinwahl auch noch mal
eine spannende Analyse gemacht auch zu
dem Thema da sagten 15 % der Wähler dass
sie vorstellen können die CDU zu wählen
wenn Sie eine glaubwürdige besser
Klimapolitik macht und dann wird jetzt
gearbeitet wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie